make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
ruffle rings I think I'm gonna start
selling these things stay tuned for
information about that so what I want to
do in this video is I want to compare
Batman the Animated Series and x-men the
animated series right and the reason why
is because these were two of the
greatest comic book shows ever made
right and I grew up on these shows but I
grew up on Batman and and x-men the
animated series
these were my go to write was the early
90s a couple of a cartoon shows were
amazing let's start with Batman let's
start with Batman the Animated Series
okay first things first the intro
freakin amazing
the 'true batman wrote a something i
used to get so hyped watching that intro
to do i I was do that that intro was
fire and it was do there was I don't
know what it was he was like the whole
orchestra right because he they hired
like I'll hold like the whole crew to
like come in and and make these make the
intro for that show but like the the
whole like the whole intro do was just
something about it man like it would get
you gassed out right so you'd be like
let's get into this man let's get into
this thing the other thing about it was
actually was was the soundtrack of this
show because it wasn't just the intro
right it wasn't just the intro going
going into this whole thing
it was the soundtrack of the show Batman
I mean Kevin Conroy he's kind of the
voice of Batman now like and he will be
forever right like people are gonna look
at him they're gonna say that's the
voice of that everybody else is just
second best right so like they're all
getting door prizes basically it's cool
but they're no kevin conroy
right i mean i think we can all kind of
agree on that and and so because of that
you know when you when you when you look
at the way the character was was
portrayed batman was dark and brooding
and dramatic if you go and you look at
Chris Rowland's Batman trilogy yes you
have Bruce Wayne and yes you have Batman
but but you look at Bruce Wayne and he
feels like that and he feels like Batman
putting on a mask and becoming a
becoming like a regular guy right like
becoming Bruce Wayne and there's
something wrong with that but the great
thing about Batman the Animated Series
is they felt like two totally different
people but they felt like two completely
different people you have you had Batman
who was just like dark and brooding and
you were probably afraid he was gonna
kill you
and then you had Bruce Wayne who was
just like yeah man I get laid like all
the time because I'm rich and I'm hot
it was it was basically it was it was it
was crazy to kind of see it unfold
Alfred was was probably one of the
coolest characters there right because
Alfred was cool he was laid-back if he
was tone down and and it was interesting
not to see him kind of do his thing you
know and to kind of be like master Bruce
you know and so on and so forth he was
really kind of what you expect Alfred to
be but here's where I think that man the
animated series really stood out the
villains the villains I think are what
really made Batman the Animated Series
so cool and that's one of the things
I've always talked about right is one of
the reasons why I've always said that I
think the future are coming but movies
are gonna move away from superheroes and
start focusing more on villains because
oftentimes the villains are more
interesting than the heroes depending on
how the story's done and and and you
look at somebody like the Riddler right
the Riddler was really really cool what
was what was what was the name of the
episode um if you're so smart why aren't
you rich I think is where you're
introduced to introduced to Edward nygma
ah but like the riddle of the minotaur
dude it's like one of the most exciting
episodes ever right like the hand of
fate like Shh and then it carries him
away and it's just dude it was like it
was one of the most exciting things ever
right it was it was such a cool episode
but I loved the riddles because the cool
thing about those the episodes with the
Riddler the cool thing about them is
while the episodes were entertaining it
was as much fun for me to try to figure
out the answer is it was watching Batman
and Robin and then try to figure out the
answer right so I felt more immerse I
felt more involved in those episodes to
face was really really interesting the
penguin was cool like the penguin was
really really fun I loved Hugo Strange
right what was the episode there was
like ever the name of it but I think it
was the secret of Bruce Wayne but it was
the episode where Hugo Strange had been
blackmailing people by basically
parading himself as a people as a person
that can help people get through like
their worst moment for things that
really caused him the most grief and he
was secretly recording that right and
then use that information and see like
you have to give me some money or do me
political favors or something like that
or I'm gonna release this to the world
and I want to say it was like it was
like a judge or some chick like that who
would uh who would set off the Gotham
City Fire when she was a little kid I
came over I never what her name was
which is kind of ironic cuz I watched
the episode like three weeks ago but uh
but but like it was cool stuff like that
honestly elephant in the room right the
standout star of Batman the Animated
Series these stand out star the stand
out star was the Joker
here's the thing man here is the thing I
like all my favorite episodes of Batman
the Animated Series have the Joker and
the written and and it's just because he
was as goofy and silly as he was
dangerous and the end and the laughs
dude the laughs the Joker's laugh I love
the Joker's laugh because I would crack
up I couldn't help but laugh whenever I
heard the Joker's left more camel did
that perfect but it was a small little
thing that made the Joker's so memorable
right like there's there's one episode
where the Joker floods the entirety of
Gotham City with with either like
laughing gas or Joker talk show I don't
think was Joker toxin because people
weren't like they didn't become you know
didn't like die as versions of the Joker
but he flooded the entire city of Gotham
and then sort of like ransacking the
place and there's a scrape mode is this
one that has captain clown
and there's do captain clown did I love
captain clown you killed captain clown
dude I loved captain clown he was
amazing the idea here was that they were
on a boat and they basically rode up to
the to the docks and like and you got
that amazing that amazing dude
you give us amazing music and the Joker
and all his henchmen come out with
grocery carts you know and he's like now
everyone remember where we parked it was
it was stuff like that man
like it was it was these these hilarious
little things there's there's there's
one moment there was there was one
hilarious moment I think it was the
Christmas special and it was the one
where Joker had taken over one of the
television stations and he had taken
like Commissioner Gordon and and the
main reporter chick and maybe one or two
other people hostage and Batman had to
go and rescue them and so Batman
eventually catches up with the Joker and
like the Joker gives him a box give him
like a present right I know a lot of you
guys know what I'm talking about Joe
gives me more present and and Batman
opens it up and it's just like like a
hand comes out and puts up high in his
face
it was the small little things it was a
small little things it was merrily the
schemes of the Joker that made him
entertaining because they were pretty
pretty straightforward right like the
Joker has a scheme he wants to rob stuff
you know and that's basically yet but
the adaptation because basically Joker
from Batman him and his series was Steve
Englehart run on the Joker like it was
Steve Englehart run on Batman in the
anime
and so like Joker trying to copyright
fish you know like like different things
like that the Joker was a Joker's favor
the one where like um that guy cuts him
off and then like the Joker chases him
down but it was it was small little
things like that you know it was it was
it was I think I was actually the one
where Harley Quinn was introduced but it
was small little things like that Joker
I think really elevated Batman the
Animated Series to a whole new level
right because for all of us who are
watching it was always one of these
things where it was like we want to see
Batman and the Joker face off against
each other and seeing Joker transcend
the animated series right see him go
into Batman mask of the phantasm was
even cooler right what was what was oh
my god dude what was that scene there's
there's there's this hilarious moment in
Batman mask of the phantasm I was a
Salva Lester who was a mobster Agana the
Joker for help and the Joker basically
killed him right and so you didn't know
he was dead like all you knew was a man
the phantasm goes walking into sal
valestra place right he's like sal
valestra your angel of death awaits you
knows it was really cool the voice of
the phantasm was all amazing and so like
like as soon as that happens like sal
valestra is like in a chair the chair
spins around in the newspaper falls down
or something like that and like there's
this camera that looks up and the Joker
is like whoops guess the joke's on me it
was hilarious like like Joker blows the
place up he's like hello operator
I believe my party's been disconnected
things like that little moments like
that made the show fantastic right just
just absolutely elevated the show from
like this comic book show to somebody
that would just stand there would last
forever right there there would be like
one of the most definitive comic
adaptations ever so from there I want to
shift over to the x-men the intro to
that show much like that man the
animated series was fired like seeing
all the characters and things like that
you know in the end the soundtrack it
was it was cool you know like today well
it's just it's it's unlikely you hear
that song and you immediately know worse
from your like x-men the anime series
the song was ripped off from some guy in
Europe but it's still cool it was it was
a it was a really really it was it was
it was an amazing intro from there I
think that extra in the animated series
the soundtrack didn't match Batman the
enemies
it's right it wasn't on that same level
because they don't really bring in like
a whole Orchestra for the soundtrack
well I mean the soundtrack of I think
even in some instances what was
happening like the the background music
of the soundtrack and extra animated
series didn't always match the tone of
what was going on at the time and so I
think with that man am in a series it
almost always match the tone like it's
set the stage for what was going on you
know a dark and brooding moment Batman's
dark and broody the song sounds dark and
pretty with expedited series it was a
lot more I wouldn't say it was a lot
more rock-oriented right like you know
electric guitars different things like
that which was fine for what it was
because I think it was it was designed
to be a more kind of in-your-face sort
of situation but having said that the
stories in x-men am in a series I think
beat out Batman the Animated Series I
really think they do and the reason why
is because the because you know I could
sit down and and and I can I can
basically watch through entire seasons
of x-men the animated series without
really getting bored there were a few
episodes here and there where I got
kinda bored you know like the story of
the Morlocks different okay you know
that's cool I guess watching storm fight
Callisto whatever but but but sitting
down and and watching like pound for
pound watching the episodes and just
going like from one season to the next
it only got better as time goes on and
there were there were some episodes that
that really stood out right like one
man's worth which was a two-part episode
and it basically showed what would
happen if Xavier died before he could
create the x-men and instead of being
there like a war breaks out between
humans and mutants and magneto is
leaving what what not really even the
x-men just the mutant resistance but
it's cool to watch that episode and see
like mr. sinister fighting alongside
like like the mutant population against
humanity it was cool little things like
that time fugitives was a fantastic
episode right the episode where Cable
has to basically go into the past and
help apocalypse defeat the x-men in
order to ensure the timeline like the
survival of his future ultimately he
ends up finding a different way and they
sort of incorporated the legacy virus
into it but but you know looking at
those things as signals were really
really awesome to see watching magneto
sort of lose his mind on on various
heroes was was was amazing to see as far
as the episodic events go they were cool
Reilly there was a really good episode
where we're not not mimic um morph that
was that was adhered to morph who was
actually crative for the show and and
didn't really appear in the comics until
much much later on uh but to see the
episode you know we were like morph
donning like the first
two or three episodes I think it was he
died I think in the second part of night
of the signals although I think was when
they lost her attack against a Sentinel
base but for a morph to have been killed
right and then to have been taken by mr.
sinister and then to have his mind
warped and then basically be brought
back and then and then basically become
like a villain there was a really good
episode where I don't think was called
Redemption uh I it was it was a woman it
was a one named episode but it was
basically where more of handle like kind
of regain his bearings right and so
there was this amazing sequence of
events where morph I think is facing off
against the symbols in mastermold
and he starts like shifting into all
these different different mutants and
using their powers like he's basically
like a one-man army when I when I look
at the various characters in the show
right like Wolverine obviously they
couldn't do they couldn't have a show
where Wolverine killed people so will
rein would like slash and tear apart
like like you know robots and and like
the robot henchmen of the Hellfire Club
and like the Sentinels and things like
that and it was that was that was kind
of cool to see you know looking at the
characters the great thing about this
it's for the most part each one of the
characters stood on their own
Nightcrawler stood on his own right you
looked at Nightcrawler in isolation and
he was for the most part of as a
pacifist there would only really fight
when he had to Professor X was leader of
the team but you could also tell he was
kind of a dick right he was a little bit
of a dick juggernaut was really kind of
this big lumbering buffoon but we're
still pretty cool in terms of how he was
how he was shown in terms of the power
he had how dangerous of a threat he was
seen the fight between him and gladiator
was legit as fast as it was that fight
was like that it was if I was like five
seconds long right like gladiator comes
down from Shiar space coming after Devon
Shikari coming after like what does Eric
the red is what he was masquerading as
and like juggernauts hanging out with
black Tom Cassidy who's this guy that
can control plants which by the way if
you're reading x-force black Tom Cassidy
is legit now he sucked until like just
now like now he's cool but like like
like you know why he's hanging out with
black Tom Cassidy Cassidy Keith and like
like gladiator comes out and juggernauts
like to start a new trap and he's like
dude I'm not worried about this guy and
he goes to punch gladiator and nothing
happens and gladiator like picks him up
and just throws him there wasn't like
three miles you know it was it was
amazing to see that kind of stuff go on
right but you look at each one of the
characters and they all for the most
part stand on their own I think that
when it comes to the standout stars of
the show when it comes to the show where
you look at those care do you say which
ones are the best I think for a lot of
people it was gambit like
it was an amazing character in the show
but here's the thing much like Batman
the Animated Series while the show did
have like in and really really on a
solid front had some very very cool
heroes the villains were the ones who
made this show fantastic the villains
were the ones who really made the show
stand out like magneto was an amazing
character it was so cool to see him
there's this really really good moment
he kidnapped Senator Robert Kelley and
then centrioles are sent after Robert
Kelley to rescue him and and like they
they go and they they try to attack
magneto and he's all like this giant
tanker right you know and there he tried
to use his powers against him I like
your powers I'm gonna work on us like
you know we are like a durable plastic
and Magneto's like fools like I'm on a
tanker this whole thing is my weapon and
he's like totally out rivets and stuff
and just like watching these things in
the Sentinels it was it was cool like it
was it was a really a really really cool
moment there but magneto was dynamic
magneto was a guy where you looked at
him I realize he's not just like a
regular Philip but he's not just like a
regular guy where he's like I'm gonna
rob a bank
he was a guy he was basically like
Xavier philosophy doesn't work you get
really cool stories like sanctuary where
he basically crates asteroid em you get
the you get the acolytes of Magneto
Fabian Cortez who in the comments is
actually a pretty interesting character
in the show they really did injustice
but but you you get these great
depictions of magneto as a villain but
to me the standout villain of the show
the standout villain of x-men the am in
a series was apocalypse dude I love the
apocalypse he had the best one the
apocalypse had the best one-liners ever
in the history of any comic book shop
dude he was a mid I am the rocks on the
eternal SH war smash against me and be
broken dude he was it was dudes like the
most ballin thing ever right like like
wouldn't doing that guy showed up you're
like oh man that's not you just get
ready to pop off it was it was amazing
right because he could do pretty much
anything and like in and here's here's
the coolest thing about the way that
apocalypse was depicted in the show in
terms of the power he possessed the way
he talks the guy who voiced him over how
like intimating he was apocalypse had
this sort of like imposing presence in
the show right like like apocalypse
shows up and like every like you kind of
had this lingering feeling like
everybody was gonna die but like you
know like at any moment they could all
be killed by apocalypse because all the
x-men can never really do is
hold him off and that was one of the
coolest things that was shown between
the comics that really that really was
kind of elevated in the comics under
Luis and Walter Simonson an x-factor and
unlike the actual x-men the animated
series well as they could never really
defeat apocalypse all they could do was
just kind of keep him at bay they could
defeat his horsemen they could pass the
testing and then ultimately apocalypse
would go back to whatever was he was
doing before but they can never really
defeat him he was just too powerful of a
foe and it was cool to see that
integrated into the comics so he wasn't
just like a villain of the day kind of
guy where it's like well they find
apocalypse and apocalypse is dead now
moving on like it wasn't really anything
that basic or that simple Beyond Good
and Evil was a four part series where
epochal it was basically the twelve from
Marvel Comics - the scrolls and
apocalypse had essentially captured like
12 of the most powerful psychics in
existence across the universe and then
brought them all to to a place outside
of time - the Nexus of time and
basically it took like the x-men and
whoever else they could gather to defeat
apocalypse and it was cool to see that
whole thing happened right like he was
just this imposing figure this imposing
character and so having said all of that
like like looking at these two shows
reasonably right like looking at these
two shows for what they are sitting down
and comparing you know between the
between the episodic progression of the
shows the characters in the show the
soundtracks of the show and leaving
nostalgia out of it right like like
leaving my own personal feelings of the
show out of it and looking at them
objectively in reality I'll have to go
with that man the animated series and it
hurts me to say it it hurts me to say
the Batman the Animated Series I think
it's better but here's here's the reason
why
x-men the animated series was a great
show it was a fantastic show and the
hewers were all interesting and it was a
show that got me into comic books right
and because of x-men the animated series
I've been reading x-men ever since right
so since about 1993 1994 I've been
reading the x-men consistently right
like like year after year after year
I've always been reading the x-men but
the issue with x-men the animated series
it was following the classic three-part
narrative like the set up the the
conflict in the resolution which is
classic storytelling but you didn't
really get to see the gritty stuff in
between the nuanced things in between
and that's what really set Batman the
Animated Series apart with Batman the
Emmet is serious it was it was this
progression we go from A to B to C but
what you got to see was a and then a and
a half
and then V and then B you know and then
like B and a half and then C you got to
see what went on in between from start
to finish it was a full-on cohesive
story and and because of that because of
the fact that you you looked at Batman
animated series and you saw everything
from like top to bottom right so not
only what it was that Batman was doing
but how it impacted not just him but the
criminal element as well as like this
cities of Gotham because of how the the
the how the how the depiction of Gotham
was done and so far is like the kind of
gothic and overall tone because the
music set the tone for the show because
of all these different things and all
sort of came together to create this
kind of perfect depiction of Batman it
really I wouldn't say that like it's
Francis and absolutely crushes about
Avenue lxp in the animated series but I
do think it's better because I think
there from top to bottom the show
stronger is more cohesive and it's more
solid and it pains me to say that
because I loved x-men the animated
series so much but have you said that I
wouldn't know what you guys think I
wouldn't know what your opinions are
which one do you like more Batman the
Animated Series or x-men the animated
series and let me know if you guys want
to see more of these because this is
actually really really fun right like we
can compare other shows we can say
Batman the eMeter series versus the
Justice League Unlimited right because
that was that was a really cool show
back in the day we could you like Batman
the ohmmeter series versus Teen Titans
or Teen Titans vs spider-man the
animated series and just kind of go from
there but let me know you guys think let
me know how you guys feel about this
kind of comparison between these shows
well it being said we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
two comments explain make sure you guys
at the sub button to become part of the
robb show if you guys enjoyed or not the
rupture of the if you guys enjoyed this
video
ah if you okay let's try that again ah
if you are new here to come as explained
make sure you guys are the sub one to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]